there's just something special about the
beginning of a new console generation
and today i'm going to share with you my
top 10 ps5 games coming out for sony's
next-gen system
people of the internet retrorec and tour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
ah that sweet sweet smell of a new
console generation
and let me tell you guys i'm hyped for
some new games
after you finish with my list don't be
shy let me know down in the comments
which games you are most hyped for
because i know
i'm not going to get them all number 10
destruction all-stars
i was so happy to see destruction
all-stars move to playstation plus
even if it did come with a slight delay
of the game which is now scheduled to
hit in february of 2021.
look i grew up with twisted metal 2 and
this has given me some serious
flashbacks in a good way here
although there have been numerous car
combat games over the years
in my opinion none of those have come
close to surpassing what twisted metal 2
did
even the twisted metal sequels this is
one of those games i thought had the
potential to be a real sleeper hit with
a new console launch
however i feared it would be
overshadowed by the big budget titles
such as assassin's creed and call of
duty
with limited funds after spending money
on a new console a few games and an
extra accessory or two
chances were high that destruction
all-stars was going to be left out in
the cold of a busy launch
by moving the game to playstation plus
though sony is guaranteeing there will
be a solid audience which is so
important for any game with a focus on
multiplayer
destruction all-stars features online
battles for up to 16 players as well as
a single player campaign with over 50
events
number nine bug snacks okay you guys
know as a dad i'm all about the family
friendly game so i was pretty excited to
see sony feature a game like bug snacks
at the ps5 reveal event
this one immediately pops with color and
has an undeniable charm from the first
moment you see it
and hear it it reminds me a bit of
cloudy with a chance of meatballs
although its gameplay is inspired by
titles such as pokemon snap and ape
escape
it's described as a first-person
adventure game with 100 different
species of bug snacks for players to
capture
my son and i can't wait to dive in
number eight returnal
my hype for returnal is based almost
solely on my love for the devs at house
mark
i think they're one of the most
under-appreciated devs in the entire
industry resogun was a ps4 launch title
that to this day is one of my favorite
games on the system
they also made nex machina super
stardust dead nation
the list just goes on and on an
absolutely insane
quality library that sometimes went
unnoticed
returnal is a departure for them though
as they pivot away from
arcade style shooters into third person
regardless these guys know what makes
good gameplay and i
fully expect fraternal to blow folks
away when it launches
hopefully the shift into a more popular
genre will bring house mark the
attention
and sales they deserve number seven
horizon forbidden west
the big time success of horizon zero
dawn made a sequel
all but inevitable i mean come on a
third person action game with a strong
lead character
unique weaponry and dinosaur mechs yes
please give me more
the devs at gorilla are incredibly
talented as they've shown over the years
with the kill zone titles but making the
move to a game like horizon was clearly
the right move
they showed they were capable of much
more by delivering an open world action
game that also had a strong story
there's no doubt expectations will be
very high for forbidden west
number six ratchet and clank rift apart
it's hard to believe ratchet is almost
20 years
old guys for the younger ones out there
who may not remember ratchet debuted on
the playstation 2 all
the way back in 2002. seriously guys
2002.
despite his age insomniac continues to
pump out games that get better
and better than the ones before it
what's kind of crazy though is this will
be the first
truly new ratchet game since into the
nexus which released on ps3 back in
2013.
ps4 did have a ratchet game back in 2016
but it was actually a remake of the
first game
which was an incredible remake by the
way rift apart is expected to have
players
jumping quickly between different worlds
thanks in large part to the ps5
super fast ssd we don't have a release
date just yet but most
expect this one to hit in early 2021
number five spider-man miles morales
this one certainly needs no introduction
after insomniac gave us the incredibly
popular spider-man game in 2018 we
already know they have what it takes to
deliver
to be honest with you guys what
surprised me most about that 2018
version
of spider-man was how good they made the
story
it's insomniac so he knew the action and
gameplay would be top-notch but the
story really blew me away
now we'll get to play as a new
spider-man with miles morales
with the huge success of spider-man into
the spider-verse and a sequel on the way
this game comes at a perfect time
playing as miles will give gamers a
chance to explore a different character
other than peter parker
and with the story being so good in the
original game i'm excited to see what
they have planned out for miles
speaking of into the spider verse we now
have confirmation that this suit will be
in the game which is incredible not only
that insomniac went the extra mile by
giving us the option to have spider-man
move
at 12 fps now normally in a video game
we want
higher frame rates not lower but this is
a special circumstance because the frame
rate
actually would then match that of the
film making it feel
even more like you're actually playing
as miles from the spider-verse flick
you do have the option of turning it off
however if it proves too distracting or
you're just not a fan of the effect
number four kana bridge of spirits look
we already know spider-man is gonna
deliver we know horizon's gonna deliver
but maybe an
under the radar title that really
excited me from the ps5 reveal event
is kana i'm not sure there was a trailer
more impressive than what we saw with
canaan bridge of spirits
the devs at ember lab put together an
absolutely gorgeous trailer that
generated plenty of hype almost
immediately
kana is a third-person action-adventure
game that instantly reminded gamers of
something like zelda
this makes even more sense when you
consider imber lab put together a 2016
majora's mask
fan film called terrible fate check it
out if you haven't seen it it's
incredible i'll link to it down in the
description below kana is expected to be
a shorter title that the devs hope you
can comfortably complete in a weekend
who knows if this will change given the
game's recent delay
i know i'd certainly be happy with an
even longer experience if the devs
choose to go that route
i mean just look at this game it's
gorgeous number three
hogwarts legacy if you've been following
my channel already then this one
shouldn't come as much of a surprise
i pretty much grew up with harry potter
and have been dreaming for the
ultimate hogwarts game for years
avalanche software is the dev behind
this one
not to be confused with avalanche
studios known for the just cause games
there's still a lot we don't know about
hogwarts legacy and if it will be able
to live up to the undoubtedly lofty
expectations for it but what we do know
so far
looks very promising the game was leaked
more than two years ago and was
officially unveiled with a trailer at
sony's ps5 showcase event
i've covered what we know so far about
hogwarts legacy quite extensively on my
channel here so click the interactive
card above if you're looking for more
info
on that one moving on though to number
two
demon souls not gonna lie to you guys it
took me multiple
tries to get into the souls games i
think i deleted demon souls off my ps3
more than once before it finally clicked
and i understood
what all the fuss was about i went on to
play all of the other souls games as
well as securo and consider them to be
among my favorite games of all time from
what we've seen so far it looks like the
devs at blue point have done a
phenomenal job at taking that ps3
classic
and putting a glorious glorious fresh
coat of paint on it to make it look
absolutely incredible on the ps5 fans of
the original though are even more
excited about the frame rate
and no sony this doesn't mean you're off
the hook for bloodborne and at number
one
we have god of war ragnarok god awarded
something that
few franchises are able to accomplish
and that it took what was an incredibly
popular formula and completely turned it
on its head
and actually succeeded doing it as much
as i appreciate the original god of war
games for what they were there's no
doubt in my mind that the new version is
even better they replace the angry
destroy everything in his path kratos
with someone much
more relatable even for a god the
relatability factor came as a result of
his son atreus
or maybe you remember him as boy
you thought i was gonna spoil it didn't
you nope nope not here not on this
channel
if you have no idea what i'm talking
about hurry up and play god of war
already for real
it wasn't just the story though the
combat upgrades how you move through the
world pretty much
everything was changed from the old
school god of war games
a sequel was inevitable and all we have
so far is the cryptic teaser trailer but
honestly
that's really all we need to get hyped
for a new god of war
that's gonna be it for today's video as
always thank you guys so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon